welcome back to cbs saturday morning
it's been called the worst fire here in
new york city in a generation traced to
a malfunctioning space heater the blaze
broke out in a bronx apartment building
on january 9 killing 17 people including
eight children many building residents
fled with just the clothes on their
backs but over the last two weeks new
yorkers of all backgrounds have stepped
in to help their diversity reflecting
that of the city itself nancy chin has
their story
as thick smoke engulfed the building
firefighters rescued delaney rodriguez
and her family from the apartment they
lived in for 16 years we got out with
the pajamas we had
and i took just the shoes i have
and
run with my kids and they survived
without much more for days until they
found faith a few miles down the road
in the aisle of a target rodriguez was
comforted by a diverse group of
community leaders strangers are here to
help you and god bless you for that
tusha diaz the founder of latino muslims
of new york as well as an active
chaplain and reverend camisario were
also at the store helping families
gather anything they needed what did you
buy
i buy pampers wipers pajamas
shampoos conditioners that we didn't
have at this moment because everything
is locked in the house and the majority
of the stuff that i have is is damaged
the rodriguez's were one of three
families this remarkable group of
shopping companions brought along five
thousand seven hundred twenty and
sixteen cents
yeah
and that's one that's one family we're
gonna do another few
as they assist those affected one at a
time alex rappaport heads must be a soup
kitchen which also donated 120 food
warmers accompanied by the message with
love from the jewish community america
is a mosaic of goodness people coming
together all the time and trying to make
it whole for the people who are broken
that's all we try to do many of the
families who lived in the building are
muslim including the 17 people killed
mosbia provided food in line with
islamic religious dietary standards
joining others on the ground including
muslims giving back
the nonprofit delivered hundreds of
halal meals to families and first
responders in the days after the fire
stopping by the mosque where victims had
worshipped imam musa they're doing
everything to make us forget about
what's happened to us even though we
can't forget about what's happening but
they are bringing happiness into our
heart reverend disarro says their
different beliefs only strengthen what
they offer because in situations like
this
people can lose hope in humanity
but then here we come from different all
different faith backgrounds a muslim a
christian
a jew
right all united together
on united front which shows that there's
strength in unity a community keeping
the faith when we were walking out here
i said to you so many shopping carts and
you said so many blessings for cbs
saturday morning nancy chen new york
uh it certainly does
bring a smile and just a warm feeling
we need to hear this the mosaic of
goodness
that really stands out because we see so
much of the other side and in a moment
like this put your faith aside it's
about humans human beings humanity i say
about 50 000 in food necessities has
come in so far with more
coming along the way